[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir au travail
détachées en europe un travailleur et 10
des tâches et lorsqu'il est employé de
façon ponctuelle dans un autre pays que
le sien cette mobilité des travailleurs
est autorisé depuis une directive de
1996 mais des problèmes sont apparus
depuis
beaucoup dénoncent du travail dissimulé
des conditions déplorables le fameux
dumping social nous en parlerons de
nouvelles lois tente de remédier à ces
dérives et de mieux encadrer le travail
détaché alors quelle solution contre ces
abus avec nous pour en débattre daniel
taravella vous êtes président de la
fédération française du bâtiment
yvelines il gobbi vous êtes secrétaire
fédéral en charge des travailleurs
détachés à la cgt construction et
florence mercadé choqué vous êtes
avocate spécialisée en droit du travail
bonsoir à tous s'associant daniel
taravella la question que se posent
beaucoup de gens pourquoi une entreprise
de btp à tel recours à des travailleurs
détachés plutôt que les travailleurs
locaux
écoutez je pense qu'il ya une
explication qui est toute simple c'est
là que d'une part surtout le contexte
économique tout simplement
c'est à dire c'est à dire que nous avons
affaire à des maîtres d ouvrage qui de
plus en plus vont vers le moins disant
ci est le mieux
dix ans est très éloigné c'est à dire
toujours le moins cher et on arrive
aujourd'hui à une situation où les prix
de marché dans le bâtiment sont souvent
sont souvent inférieurs aux prix aux
coûts de production donc bien évidemment
pour pouvoir sortir leur épingle du jeu
les entreprises sont obligées de faire
appel à la sous traitance cela au
détriment de du personnel français si je
peux français entre guillemets puisque
dans le bâtiment il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de nationalités et est donc ça
devient malheureusement une nécessité je
dis malheureusement parce que c'est pas
forcément là ce que les gens souhaitent
au départ il faut malheureusement c'est
une nécessité mais écoutez déjà le
travail le travail des tâches et n'est
pas en soi un problème puisque
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui en europe on peut travailler
dans les différents pays européens
aujourd'hui nous ce que nous rencontrons
sur nos différents chantiers c'est comme
le disait monsieur des travailleurs
détachés qui viennent des différents
pays pour lorgner roumanie et qui
travaillaient dans des conditions
vraiment excécrable qui sont logés dans
des taudis qu'ils sont payés bien bien
bien en dessous du smic
et là nous apercevoir mais effectivement
des dérives qu'il y a sur en même temps
sur le travail de la sous traitance la
sous traitance que nous rencontrons nous
sommes au chantier on appelle ça la sous
traitance en cascade
florence marqué les chaudières à bienne
où justement les règles on parle de sous
traitance clarifier un peu tout ça selon
cette directive voilà 2,96 alors je
pense que le ces dérives sont liées à
l'absence de réactivité
législatives aussi bien en france que au
niveau de l'europe puisque la directive
comme vous l'avez rappelé l et de 1996
mais la directive d'exécution dans les
pays européens les de 2014
donc on s'est retrouvé entre 1996 et
2000 14 avec un espèce de vide est une
application de la directive dans un
certain nombre de pays européens
les non-dits cac et à quel niveau au
niveau 2 à tous quelle qu'elle rêve
quelle condition de kavala on est parti
sur le fait qu'il y avait une liberté
d'aller et venir et de travailler
partout en europe ce qui est tout à fait
le cas est-ce que vous rappeliez mais il
n'y avait pas d'encadrement sur le plan
de droit du travail puisqu'on n'a pas
d'harmonisation en europe du droit
social
chaque pays a son propre droit social
ses propres règles et on n'a pas
d'harmonisation européenne du droit du
travail
ils font ce qu il précisé cette
directive dit que le travailleur doit
être engagée aux conditions du pays
il faudra une frappe à sa directive soit
ensuite adapté à chaque droit national
et donc il ya eu cette directive
d'exécution européenne qui n'a été
entendu qu'en 2014 est derrière vous
avez eu un arsenal juridique français
qui est quand même assez exigeant
vis-à-vis de la société étrangère et
vis-à-vis des donneurs d'ordre les
maîtres d'ouvragé en france vous avez
une première loi qui la loi savary qui
est de 2014 ensuite vous avez la loi
macron quai de 2015 et vous avez là l'ol
comrie 2016 et tout cet arsenal a
renforcé les obligations de chacun avec
des sanctions qui sont relativement
importantes et surtout avec une
responsabilité solidaire des donneurs
d'un des maîtres d'ouvragé avec les
sociétés étrangères qui ne
respecteraient pas les formalités
obligatoires qu'elle doit faire avant et
même avant d'envoyer un salarié détaché
en france donc je pense que là ça
commence à faire effet puisque les
sanctions commencent à tomber
il ya des contrôles qui ont comme en
2015 devait y avoir à peu près 500
contrôles qui ont été faits on a
sa piste 2016 oui maintenant on a
beaucoup plus de contrôle en a mille
cinq cents contrôles qui ont été faits
en 2016 il ya une collègue d'amande
d'environ quatre millions et demi
puisque les amendes peuvent être jusqu'à
10000 euros par salarié en cas
d'infraction de la part de la société
étrangères s'explique par sa vaillance à
s'applique à la société étrangère et
avec une responsabilité solidaire du
donneur d'ordre ou du maître d'ouvragé
en france donc on a des amendes soit
jusqu'à 10000 euros sur certaines
infractions et d'autre jusqu'à 2000
euros par salarié sur d'autres
infractions mais sur des infractions qui
peuvent être au delà de ce que vous
disiez monsieur qui sont des infractions
graves sur des problématiques
d'hébergement effectivement où il y à
des salariés détachés qui sont hébergées
de façon un peu scandaleuse en france il
y à des amendes qui sont prononcés ne
serait-ce que si la société étrangère
avant de détacher un salarié en france
elle doit faire une déclaration à
l'inspection du travail de détachement
avant de détacher et elle doit également
maintenant depuis le mois de mars avoir
une carte professionnelle va en parler
voilà donc il ya des formalités
extrêmement rigoureuse des contrôles qui
commence à vraiment à se mettre en place
et puis bon je pense qu'il faut aussi un
renforcement au niveau des agents de
contrôle administratif même si ça s'est
étendu
on en parlera d'accord ça assure daniel
taravel ajustements
donc ils gobbi disait des abus qu'est ce
que vous répondez à cela je dis je pense
que c'est effectivement vrai il ya
effectivement des abus sissili a déjà bu
je me dis que possible ses amis ce sont
des heures de travail qui ne sont pas
il ya effectivement il ya des heures
peut-être qu'ils ne sont pas rémunérés
mais ce qu'il ya surtout si un nombre
est un non respect du temps de travail
légal puisque ces gens là souvent
travaillent dix heures par jour et sept
jours par semaine
bon et j'ose dire au risque de peut-être
de choquer j'ose dire qu'ils le font un
petit peu en toute tranquillité parce
que jusqu'à nouvel ordre
durant les week-ends on ne voit pas
d'inspection du travail sont les
chantiers donc les gens sont tranquilles
et peuvent faire à peu près ce qu'ils
veulent à ce niveau là cela étant si
elle du travail régulier il faut dire
aussi qu'il y à du travail et des tâches
et régulier et nous nous avons toujours
eu vrai nous ne sommes pas contre le
travail détachées en revanche ce qui
nous perturbe
et ce qui perturbe nos entreprises et ce
qui pénalise nos entreprises c'est que
même à salaire égal si tenté que ça
existe le problème ce sont les charges
puisque on arrive à des différentiels de
coûts qui sont facilement de l'ordre de
30 à 40% selon les pays sur les charges
et c'est là où effectivement nous
considérons c'est la dérange aux
entreprises
c'est une concurrence déloyale puisque
ces gens là arrivent avec des coûts qui
sont nettement inférieurs d'où ce que je
disais en préambule la tentation la
forte dans ta tion d'aller vers la sous
traitance pour essayer d'être
concurrentiels si je fais juste rapporté
que les les salariés détachés
effectivement doivent être soumis au
droit du travail français
donc c'est surtout ce qui est peut-être
libertés individuelles collectives tout
ce qui peut être protection de
de maladie de maternité de congé
parental durée du travail justement ils
sont assujettis et la durée du travail
française et tout certain nombre
d'obligations d'égalité homme-femme
d'égalité professionnelle etc
mais il n'en demeure pas moins que
aujourd'hui les entreprises étrangères
paye les charges sociales dans leur pays
d'origine et c'est ça qui va faire la
différence de factures entre guillemets
pour les entreprises françaises
puisqu'elles n'auront que le coût du
salaire qui doit être au moins deux
semaines de salaire minimum légal ou
conventionnel en france qui doit être
respecté mais les charges n'étant pas
les mêmes c'est clair que au final la
facture pour les entreprises françaises
et moins cher il faut bien c'est le
problème que vous avez identifié aussi
ce différentiel entre les charges
sociales
bien sûr les cotisations les cotisations
sociales si c'est bien entendu pour pour
une entreprise un coot mais pour nous
nous nous revendiquons le fait qu'une
entreprise quand elle détache salariés
détachés
il faudrait effectivement qu'elles
paient des cotisations sociales dans le
pays
dans le pays d'accueil vim enfin voila
apres après reste à charge à nos
administrations à nos administrations de
régler le problème de des cotisations
entre les deux administrations la
portugaise et française alors pour que
le thé spectateur comprenne bien
expliqué nous bien donc l'entreprise le
sous traitant est par exemple je sais
pas m'en bologne voilà en roumanie
expliquez-nous prenez des exemples
concrets pour peu qu'on comprenne bien
mais c'est trop cette fois ci
une entreprise détache un travailleur
est une entreprise basée à une
entreprise basée par exemple en pologne
en pologne à la détache un travailleur
en france travaillent à un travailleur
en france nous ce que ce qu'on dit déjà
c'est que il faut qu'ils la le respect
du travail égal salaire égal qui n'est
pas du tout respecté aujourd'hui en
france et est hélas nous avons des
exemples sur les différents chantiers
que les visiteurs chaque fois que nous
pouvons et nous ce que nous disons c'est
que ces cotisations sociales devraient
être payés dans en france tout
simplement
alors qu'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui l'entreprise qui
détache un travailleurs détachés elles
ne payent les cotisations sociales dans
son pays d'origine mais ça c'est en lien
avec les conventions bilatérales avec la
mairie qu'il ya des textes qui régissent
ce mode c'est tout à fait légal tout à
fait légale et il n'est pas payé
non mais faut pas oublier non plus qu'il
y à peu près de cent mille français qui
sont détachés à l'étranger et qui payent
leurs cotisations sociales en france
donc il faut pas non plus qu'on a un
effet boomerang sur nana 200 mm qui sont
détachés en france
deux cent mille français détaché à
l'étranger mais qui cotisent bien en
france donc il faut faire aussi attend
jeunes à boire à manger une fuite des
réalisation les précisions sur le nombre
de travailleurs détachés qui a évolué
depuis 2002 5
il y avait 25 mille travailleurs
détachés dont environ 6500 déclarations
et aujourd'hui nous avons en 2001 2002
15 environ 300 milles de travailleurs
détachés avec 82 mille déclaration donc
il ya un problème va bien madame tout à
leur parler d'un document de ces
documents a un qui doit l'être
qu'est ce que ces documents c'est la
déclaration de détachement de
détachement donc beaucoup d'entreprises
ne remplissent pas cette déclaration
alors ensuite nous
le grand problème que nous rencontrons
c'est que non seulement on ne déclare
pas avec ce document
mais après la difficulté de contrôler
c'est vrai il a eu des contrôles on peut
pas le nier des contrôles des des agents
des agents d'inspecteurs du travail il y
en a eu mais pas assez aujourd'hui nous
ce qu'on demande également c'est le
renforcement des inspections surprises
et les moyens du côté de l'as conseillé
de travailler plus de moyens pour
l'épauler direct et en même temps nous
on demande aussi plus de moyenne pour
les institutions représentatives du
personnel
parce qu'aujourd'hui monsieur tout à
leur disais c'est une entreprise c'est
celle de moins de 10 ans sur des marchés
si les institutions représentatives du
personnel était je dirais dans la boucle
lors des démarches et on s'apercevrait
automatiquement qu'il y a ce les sous
traitants ce qui se met qui se met en
place et automatiquement le dumping
social derrière avec des travailleurs
détachés sur ce point donc faire
impliquer les syndicats en fait
dans les dents les day les marchés
publics enfin moi ça je ne vois pas ce
qu'elle forme et 21 intervenir au niveau
de la décision sur marchés publics
ce que je constate simplement un cela
étant je sais pas du tout reposer sur le
principe pourquoi pas mais je passe
quelque chose je constate au moins une
chose c'est que nous sommes à peu près
tous les trois d'accord sur les
conséquences des choses moi ce que je
dis c'est qu'en matière de marchés
publics et effectivement je connais bien
le problème des marchés publics puisque
j'ai une entreprise qui travaille à 80 %
marchés publics
bon on constate que bien que aujourd'hui
les textes donnent la possibilité
d'écarter ce que l'on appelle les offres
anormalement basses
bon il s'avère que cela ne se fait
pratiquement jamais et pour une raison
essentielle c'est que les élus ont une
crainte énorme c'est qu'on les taxe de
délit d de délit de favoritisme
donc on n'ose pas écarter l'entreprise
parce qu'on va dire c'est parce qu'il a
essayé de favoriser un autre et cela et
nous allons toujours vers le prix le
plus bas le prix de booba est encore une
fois arrive un moment où il ya un seuil
qui peut pas franchir sauf par des
moyens détournés
effectivement ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure par la sous traitance en cascade
c'est une évidence on est bien d'accord
maintenant sur les contrôles
vous avez évoqué le sujet tout à l'heure
où madame plus tôt vous savez que la
fédération du bâtiment est à l'origine
de la carte congés payés
j'ai des salariés elle parle de la carte
d'identification d'identification
alors dès aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui
cette carte est obligatoire pour tous
les personnels détachés alors
normalement quand j'ouvre un disque ça
va être assez inefficace ben je peux
enfin se dire si une destinée à un
contrôle d'un agent de l'inspection du
travail il suffit de demander les cartes
ici tout tout salarié qui n'a pas de
carte peut être peut être exclu et puis
y avoir une injonction d'administration
de justifier de la régularité de sept
personnes sur le chantier les passants
mais il faut des effets des moyens vol
ils sont nous le pensons le contraire
puisque cette carte déjà existé il ya
déjà quelques années elle a été dit et
moi même qui suis le salarié de du btp
j'imagine j'en ai une
et alors nous ce qu'on trouve quand même
assez assez aberrant c'est qu'on
n'arrive pas à comprendre comment édité
une carte alors c'est des employeurs qui
vont payer cette carte
et c'est là c'est la caisse des congés
qui gérera celle ci alors nous on pose
une question de monsieur je pense que
vous avez dû certainement entendu dire
de notre fédération
cette revendication nous ne comprenons
pas comment à la caisse des congés payés
il n'y aurait pas un système de parité
pour faire fonctionner cette caisse
justement ça veut dire quoi un système
de parité c'est bien rentrer entre les
organisations d'employeurs et les
organisations de salariés pour bonnart
dans quel but
dans le but de cobra mangeait recettes
notamment cette carte
et pourquoi pas par la suite les projets
mais en quoi la parité ferait que ce
serait plus de la carte serait plus
efficace parce que c'est c'est tout
simplement pour le contrôle aujourd'hui
nous avons aucun contrôle sur ce qu'il y
aura effectivement été sur cette carte
passive la carte a les ailes et
obligatoires du 22 mars selon qu'elle
existe bien sûr elle existe mais il ya
il
aucun contrôle pour les organisations
syndicales de savoir qu'est ce que c'est
qu'il ya écrit sur cette carte quoi
voilà il a c'est dans le décret
d'application
bien sûr je sois ce que je suis pas sûr
que je passe je passe ou au contraire un
e auditeur de cette carte au lieu
d'avoir mis autant d'argent sur sur
cette carte l'enjeu parce que encore une
fois et je pèse mes mots
il faut bien entendu et c'est une des
revendications il faut obligatoirement
pour qu'il y ait plus de contrôle il
faut plus d'argent
des directs sinon on ne pourra pas on ne
pourra pas y aller
les contrôles vous savez on sait comment
ça se passe j'ai participé à des
contrôles avec des inspecteurs du
travail sur les chantiers et déjà quand
on arrive sur un échantillon d'un
inspecteur du travail tout est réglé le
chantier est propre il est vide il n'y a
plus de travailleurs détachés
je vous donne un exemple sur le chantier
du terminal méthanier qui pour nous est
un cas d'école parce que nous avons tous
vues sur ce terminal est là celui des
accidents mortels de travailleurs
détachés et on a eu de son mot mais là
j'ai un document
on a eu une fiche de paye avec un zéro
en affaires mais tapei 0 alors on
s'aperçoit travailleurs détachés
roumains alors s'aperçoit sur et châtiés
comme le terminal méthanier gros
chantier 70% de la population salariée
du chantier était de la main d'oeuvre
étrangère et les 30% et msi série
d'épisodes hélas hélas moon avait dit je
peux répondre avec le sourire sur la
parité je pense que vous savez ce que je
vais dire déjà un bon peut tout
simplement parce qu'il se trouve que la
caisse de congés payés financée
uniquement par des cotisations
patronales et non pas par des
cotisations ouvriers
donc voilà je crois que la réponse est
toute faite vous la connaissiez en
posant la question bien évidemment le
patron aussi donc cela étant cela étant
quand vous dites que vous avez fait des
contrôles et que vous et vous constatez
des choses de cet acabit là il est bien
évident que la carte va servir justement
à essayer de régulariser tout ça et
d'avoir à document qui réunisse toutes
tous les informations sur le personnel
détaché et je crois qu'on ne peut pas à
la fois faire des incantations en disant
il faut faire des contrôles il faut
faire des contrôles et parallèlement se
priver des moyens de contrôle ils ont
envie d'y aller mais je ne sais pas ce
qui est sûr ce bulletin de paye donc
j'ai déjà vu des bulletins de paye à 0
mais ça dépend de qui là dessus donc je
peux pas me prononcer là-dessus mais je
pense que le l'arsenal juridique qui est
s'est fortement durci sur les sociétés
françaises donc les donneurs d'ordre et
les maîtres d'ouvragé en france sur
leurs responsabilités et notamment
c'était en cascade sur la société
étrangère et tous les sous traitants qui
a expliqué nous justement et deux mots
ce que ce qui a changé à l'aube à
maquereau on sait que donc les donneurs
d'ordre sont impliqués ils sont
responsables en rien voilà c'est à dire
que les donneurs d'ordres ont deux
obligations ils ont un devoir de
vigilance c'est à dire qu'ils doivent
s'assurer que la société étrangère donc
son prestataire commercial étrangers a
bien fait à 7,7 en voie de déclaration
préalable
le détachement 1 avant de détacher de 2
à partir de maintenant puisque c'est
immédiatement applique avant que les
salariés détachés ont bien leur carte
professionnelle qu'ils ont bien un
représentant puisque les salaires des
sociétés étrangères doivent d'avoir un
représentant en france pour se faire un
peu la liaison avec les agents de
contrôler pour s'assurer que les
obligations sont bien sont bien fait et
ça c'est un devoir de vigilance du
donneur d'ordre si le donneur d'ordre
n'a pas la copie de ces documents là il
est senti une île et sans oublier il
doit lui faire une déclaration
subsidiaire dans les 48 heures et s'il
ne fait pas lui même la déclaration
subsidiaire immédiatement le chantier
peut être arrêté en tout cas la
prestation de service est suspendu
pendant un mois par
par l'administration donc il ya déjà un
premier point de blocage ici c'est à
dire qu'il faut ils font que les
donneurs d'ordre et les maîtres
d'ouvragés français prennent la pleine
mesure de leurs obligations en terme de
vigilance ils doivent s'assurer que l'on
du travail et bien appliqués ils doivent
s'assurer que les salariés sont hébergés
correctement etc ils ont cette
obligation là et ils doivent s'assurer
que les sous traitants de la société
étrangère ça c'est étrangère peut avoir
des sous traitants que ses sous
traitants là qu'il a agréé on remplit
également leurs obligations
et si le donneur d'ordres ne fait pas
cela il sera pécuniairement
financièrement responsable ainsi les ca
des salariés en question détachées ne
sont pas payés sur le salaire minimum y
seront responsables du paiement des
salaires
donc s'il ya un contentieux prud'homal
ce sont eux qui seront condamnés aux
prud'hommes donc il ya des condamnation
prud'homale il ya des amendes ya des
sanctions il ya des arrêts de chantiers
suffisant je pense que si il faudrait
maintenant qu'il y ait une pédagogie qui
fait probablement par votre fédération
auprès des sociétés françaises qui
l'utilisé salariés détachés en disant
attention vous avez cette possibilité-là
économiquement plus intéressante pour
vous très probablement
mais attention à vos responsabilités
attention à faire en sorte que la loi
soit parfaitement bien appliquée parce
que vous avez des responsabilités
personnelles qui sont contraventionnel
qui sont financières externes
nous avons fait nous avons fait
également une désinformation au niveau
européen puisque nous avons créé un
réseau européenne sur le
les droits des détachés et nous avons
créé des plaquettes différentes langues
différentes
informer les travailleurs exactement dix
ans la voix sur leurs droits et sur le
fait qu'ils peuvent lancer un recours ou
en tout cas si jamais il ya abus ils
peuvent lors des jo de londres
on les a informés de leurs droits comme
disait madame assurons les déclarations
le document à eux si tout était en règle
et en même temps sur leurs 3 bien
entendu leurs droits en termes de
salaires égalité de traitement mais
aussi avec les grilles des salaires dans
le négatif dans le bâtiment et les
travaux publics
voilà donc cette information a été a été
lancé au niveau européen parce que nous
avons travaillé également des syndicats
européenne par pas que avec des
syndicats nous avons travaillé aussi
avec les inspecteurs du travail qui ont
été sollicités pour que l'on puisse se
mettre ensemble ces informations là sous
forme de sous forme de plaquettes et
pour les airs pour compléter ce que vous
dites c'est que les deux ans dans lé
maître d'ouvragé doivent sur les
chantiers faire de l'affichage dans la
langue des salariés détachés de leurs
efforts de leurs obligations et de la
réglementation qui s'applique donc ils
doivent le faire également et s'ils ne
le font pas c'est susceptible demande
aussi si daniela ça devient compliqué
vous de votre côté toutes ces solutions
vont dans le bon sens bien évidemment
est bon la fédération du bâtiment
effectivement également fait oeuvre
d'information auprès de ses adhérents et
elle a aussi fortement appuyé pour que
les maîtres d ouvrage soit aussi
impliqué puisque encore une fois tout le
tout par duo et tout part de là et dès à
présent je crois que votre pourrait se
confirmer il ya eu déjà des dc
justice qui ont condamné ou c'est bien
les entreprises que les maîtres d
ouvrage par celui d'arrêter pour du
travail non déclaré ou irréguliers dû
simuler et sur ce problème des charges
sociales que vous soulevez y est tout à
leur 100e à la solution ce serait il
arrivé effectivement à faire en sorte
que les entreprises étrangères payer
leurs charges sociales en france on dit
tout à fait d'accord sur ce point là ou
alors d'uniformiser mais ça c'est à nos
yeux il y à il ya un certain nombre de
pays qui ont poussé la en 2016 pour
pouvoir faire avancer durcir justement
les termes de la directive sur ces
problématiques là aussi de charge
sauf que on a un vent debout de tous les
pays d'europe de l'est
les agents pour quelle raison parce que
actuellement leur leurs salariés sont
favorisés que 6 et que si on revient
effectivement à payer les charges
sociales en france car là bas ils vont
perdre leurs avantages
bien évidemment ça passe pas comme et
comme il faut l'unanimité pour prendre
des décisions
il est bien évident qu'aujourd'hui la
roumanie la pologne et c'est freine des
quatre fers sur un smic européen
justement il veut bien votre avis parler
d'usiné comme on paie on en a un ça a
été évoqué oui il alors le smic européen
quand on voit la différence de
traitement qu'il ya entre chaque pays
fait unique européenne bien entendu nous
ramener un ça va de 200 euros j'ai garé
à 2,8
luxembourg c'est pour ça que cette
disparité qu'un travailleur travailleurs
polonais qui viennent en france et qui
qui fait qu'ils gagnent un smic à 1000 à
1200 euros
on voit très bien la grande difficulté
même nous organisations syndicales que
nous avons à les rencontrer parce que
ils nous disent matane et je gagne 1200
euros dans mon pays c'est 200 euros donc
voilà alors oui pour vous résumer que
européenne mais le chemin le chemin si
on va être serré très bien sur quel sens
sa ligne voilà exactement le chemin va
être très longue surtout que la
directive au niveau européen est en
train d'être discuté et il me semble un
peu plus dans les médias qu'il aurait
aux pays qui ne serait pas du tout
d'accord pour la réviser donc c'est pas
du tout finie espérer à blanchir un mot
de l'occident à chacun allez-y flanc le
mot de conclusion c'est appliquons la
loi
la difficulté avec des dernières lois
qui sont avec les absolument avec la loi
absolument il ya des garde-fous qui sont
la loi est là il ya tous les mécanismes
juridiques qui existent
le problème ce que disait monsieur c'est
un problème d'application c'est un
problème humain c'est un problème de
moyens pour pouvoir contrôler l'ensemble
des ouvriers parce qu'il ya des ouvriers
détachés mais pas que quoi daniel tard
avait là où les prises de contrôle aussi
a bien évidemment de la pression à tout
à fait nos entreprises sont bien
évidemment d'accord pour lé contrôle
puisque encore une fois elle souffre
souffre des gens qui travaillent de
façon irrégulière donc on est tout à
fait d'accord pour les contrôler
je crois que tout le monde est d'accord
ici autour de cette table sur des
contrôles plus fréquents et plus
efficace surtout alors j'ai pas trop par
quel moyen mais plus efficace pour un
respect bien évidemment de la
législation puisqu'elle existe et puis
pour une tentative d'amélioration pour
faire en sorte que les choses soient
égaliser au niveau européen d'une façon
ou d'une autre est juste il faudrait
deux phases arrêtées le dumping
commercial de la part des grands
donneurs d'ordre y compris d'état il
combine deux mots alors de montrer très
rapidement nous donner des moyens mais
dans tel duo s'est dit aux syndicats
pour qu'on puisse être effectivement sur
les chantiers en même temps et d aider
les corps d'état qui contrôle sur les
chantiers effectivement avoir des
contrôleurs mais surtout donner des
moyens très bien merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat s'il se retrouve
quant à nous la semaine prochaine très
bonne fin de soirée
au revoir
[Musique]